this is a very tough day for me to to
talk to the both of you very tough
really hard it's hard
life is hard
um so uh uh obviously i want to start
with congratulations on the movie um i
do uh since i have a few extra minutes
or a few minutes um mr spielberg i
wanted to ask you an individual question
obviously like everyone else i'm a
massive fan of your work um and i'm
curious which of your films in the
editing room ended up going through like
the most changes that you weren't
expecting before the finished release
oh well there's been a number of films
that went through the most changes i
think
probably terminal
uh with tom hanks
and stanley tucci i and and catherine
zeta jones that film probably went
through the most changes
uh i don't think i i can it's a good
question you ask i've never been asked
that question before great question and
and the answer popped in mine because
it's probably the only film i've made
that that had to go through so many
iterations trying to find the basic the
velocity of the story the velocity of
the narrative
could never quite find how to pace this
picture and what to lose and what to add
and what to cut down so i probably
worked on that film and editing more
than any other film i've directed wow
but it's a great question
uh thank you
thank you um uh rachel
i'm like i you know where do you go from
that i'm present too i'm frazzled on
your behalf that's a great compliment
again
i i definitely will rachel i cannot
imagine what it's like for you playing
this role on the stage in new jersey to
working with that man on your left and
i'm very curious um have you thought
about playing the lottery
it's really funny you should say that
because i constantly refer to this as me
winning the lottery yeah you do and like
it's just it's absolutely i mean with
the obviously with with the involvement
of stephen but with the whole creative
team that we got to work with janine
tasori is one of my heroes i got to meet
stephen sondheim tony kushner wrote the
screenplay justin peck was
choreographing their paul taswell
costumes adam stockhouse and sets
i mean it had the best of the best uh
even down to our crew with mitch lillian
and i just we got so i got so lucky this
is your life okay she got a chance to
meet my family because most of these
individuals who worked in west side
story have done multiple films with me
so she got to step into our family and
she and we
she was greeted and became part of it
and will always be part of it yeah thank
you
uh rachel i do have a follow-up um i
read that mckenna reynolds was the one
who
gave you the heads up that they were
casting and that she said thank me when
you're famous so i really want to know
what do you get a friend
what do you get as a present to a friend
like that who literally has changed your
life in a complete we're talking
radically
i mean it's truly it's like whatever she
wants i always tell her and she hasn't
taken me up on any offer yet mckenna is
my friend who sent me the thing yeah it
was crazy and so
um you know she gets she gets an advance
notice of when things are gonna drop i'm
just kind of like hey check twitter at
this time
she should be in the acknowledgements
it's really it's really uh she's
fantastic but i do tell her i'm like is
there someone you want to meet is there
is there a fashion brand you really like
that i can like weasel my way into um
but honestly she's she's just so
wonderful and and it's not lost on me
how fantastic of a friend she is to
think that about me and then when it
came to fruition she just she weeps
openly every time something about west
side story comes out how do you know all
these details this is amazing
um i uh i'd like to think i'm decent at
my job um i've been doing this a little
while
you know larry david says pretty good
pretty good
um this is not what i was going to say
but mr spielberg if you ever have the
time for a longer conversation i have
what we call questions and i promise i
won't waste your time you know something
i am so compelled just for this little
interview right here that would be good
for me to talk to you
um trust me when i say i i will bring my
a game um but for both of you um i don't
think enough people realize what it
really takes to make a movie they all
see the end product they see how amazing
it turns out but they don't really know
the time and energy that goes on behind
the scenes in the pre-production the
post-production can you sort of maybe
what do you wish more people knew about
movie making that maybe they just don't
know
uh i i hope they never learned anything
about moviemaking
i hope they never know i hope they never
see who's behind the curtain you know i
i think if they don't want to be a
filmmaker if they don't get into the
business and they just have they just
want to be entertained or want to be
transported somewhere
else it's best not to know too much
because you don't want to knock down
that proverbial fourth wall you want to
keep yourself safe and secure from any
knowledge other than what the story is
is throwing throwing back at you but of
course there's a whole other subset of
individuals who want to tell their
stories and they're telling them right
now on their iphones they're telling
them right now on social media and on
twitter and i mean on instagram and on
tick tock and
and uh and i i have my eye out for them
all the time because that is those are
the individuals that should know
what goes into preparing a script and
the only only piece of advice i don't
have not a lot of time but the only
piece of advice i love to give
is don't worry so much about technique
and don't worry so much about where to
put the camera or how to light
worry about one thing or think about one
thing preoccupy yourself with how do you
tell a story that's really interesting
that you can get somebody not to walk
out of the room right in the middle of
your second act if you're telling the
story how do you just tell a story that
that that people lean into what you're
saying and they don't lean back they'll
like start looking around the room
find a way first a compelling way to
express your art through your
storytelling once you've got that
there's a lot of people in this world
that will get around you and and show
you the ropes but
learning how to be a storyteller is the
most important advice i can give you
that's a fantastic answer
all right um okay well i'm gonna i don't
know rachel if you want to say anything
about movie making or you want to leave
it there
well i mean i don't
i don't know too much about movie making
i haven't made many but i will say just
the tireless effort of everybody
involved is something i wish people just
took into account a little bit more is
that you know for every 30 seconds you
see on camera there's about six days of
work that goes into it dance at the gym
was six
long days
cool was a long time the rumble was a
wrong time even a boy like that was two
whole days up one hand one heart ended
up taking two full days because
it was all it was all
it was all recorded oh i'm singing so
inc in the context in regard to our film
you know there a lot of work goes into
not only movies but this particular
movie musical it's a herculean task it
was a titanic
type movie so we we really
there's a lot of effort that goes into
every little bit that you see
thank you so much for your time have a
fantastic day i really appreciate it
thank you